so you're getting a brand new Macbook or
maybe you already got one and now you're
wondering what are some accessories that
are going to make life a lot easier and
could even save you money well today I'm
going to share the ones that we use and
that actually make a lot of sense I'm
going to skip things like mice and
random stuff like that that are very
obvious and the first one I'm going to
talk about is this little guy that I
have been using now for about a year
even though a Max can come with up to
140 W Chargers this thing is so much
smaller and instead of having just a
single USB plug this has two of them and
a high powerered USB type A so it folds
Down super small and it is just a lot
more convenient now some of the less
expensive MacBooks actually don't come
with fast charging so if you buy them
you're not going to get that so by
buying one of these and right now you
can get this thing on sale for only 65
bucks you're not only going to have
something more compact but a lot more
capable now this next one is from our
partner opal with their new tadpole this
webcam is like nothing else on the
market because it's so tiny and easy to
take with you the design is ingenious
easily clipping onto your Mac so you can
use it in seconds and it even has a mute
button built into the connector it uses
a 4K sensor so you get better video
quality but the crazy thing is the audio
is amazing because it literally only
picks up what it sees like a
professional microphone I made a full
video on it and right now you can get
15% off your order using link below and
using your code maxtech 15 next we need
to talk about ssds because I hope you
did not pay Apple's ridiculous prices
for their storage now this one right
here is a sabrin um this is a
thunderbolt version and the cool thing
about it is that it supports Thunderbolt
speeds along with USB type-c so you
canect connected to another computer and
it just works it is ridiculously fast
and mine has a 4 tbte capacity with it
um so I've been using this thing for a
couple years and it is amazing now with
that we also have the rocket you guys
can see how incredibly tiny this little
guy is right here and for 99 bucks you
get one tbte of storage whereas Apple
charges $200 to go from $52 to 1 tab so
you're really paying $200 for 512 gigs
now with that a 2 tbte costs you1 169
Apple charges
$600 and then for $3.49 you can get a 4
tbte in this tiny size now Apple will
charge you 1,000 bucks if you have a Mac
that already has 1 tbte and you can only
do that if you buy an M3 Max chip now
and that is just absolutely
insane now if you want to have
Thunderbolt speeds instead of the
highest speed USB uh you can actually
pay a little bit more for the one tab to
get that but I think most people don't
need it and the thing that I love about
having something that's external along
with my Mac um yes you do have to plug
it in so it's something extra even
though it's so small but you can use
this on multiple devices so if you have
an old machine a friends machine or
you're going to upgrade and later you
keep it it's not just tied to the system
where you pay a ton of money and then
all that money goes away because you're
not going to get that in resale and now
we have to talk about dongles because
these Macs don't have USB type A ports
and you are going to run into needing
one now you could spend I don't know
what they charge about 20 bucks for one
of these guys that I bought a long time
ago but I would say it'd be better to
buy something a little bit larger but
more capable now one of these is only 15
bucks and it gives you four USB type A
ports and the cool thing is they are 10
GB per second not five so it's double
the speed and I think that is way more
handy now you can spend a little bit
more like 30 bucks and get a few more
features or you can spend a little bit
more than that and get a high-powered
one with much more connections like
micro SD SD ethernet um and you know
pass through charging stuff like that
but I think for most people even the $15
one is plenty to take with you now the
next one that has been awesome
especially if you use your laptop on the
go is a power bank now there's so many
different options out there but I love
this one we recently went to New York I
took it with me and the thing I love
about this one is that it is very very
fast so as far as the charging speed you
can charge a 16-in Macbook from 0 to 50%
in 40 minutes from this guy right here
and the cool thing is that it also
accepts 100 Wat input so this thing
itself doesn't take four 6 8 hours like
some of the cheaper ones to charge it
charges really really quick it also has
a regular USB type a port two USB type
C's and it has one of these Barrel plugs
and on the front you also have a display
so that will show you your charging
speed for the power bank um and it'll
show you how much output is going to a
machine and I've actually used that for
testing here on the channel and then you
have customizations that you could do
inside of it it has a really large
capacity almost a Max that you can put
onto an airplane high quality and right
now they do have a $40 off coupon code
so this thing is incredible you could
buy something slow and cheap but I think
it's better spend a little bit more
money and get something that is more
powerful and that is going to last if
you spend a lot of money on a MacBook I
think it should be used as a dual
purpose with the desktop setup and that
is how I use my MacBook so with that the
first thing that's a great investment is
a nice stand to take up less room and to
make sure you have great airf flow now
this one is from 12 South it is their
Arc I've had this thing for years and
you can swap out the insert for
different size MacBooks and then if you
are a power user like I am you will need
a dock now I have used a bunch of them
and the ieni that I have set up on my
desk is by far the best one if you need
to have higher performance this thing
beats out everything else on the market
because it uses two of your Thunderbolt
ports both of them on the left hand side
and that means that you get enough
bandwidth for all of those ports with no
slowdowns other ones on the market have
less ports and even then if you're using
all of them you are going to get
slowdowns I've literally gotten
disconnections because I had so much
stuff plugged in now with those ports
you have a ton of them you have an SD
card reader a Micro SD card reader which
I use all the time and you get a bunch
of extra Thunderbolt port ports so
you're not just wasting the ones on your
machine and I have a lot of them filled
up you also have the fastest USB type-c
ports as well and because of the unique
design this thing stays super cool the
coolest dock on the market which the
other ones I've used got insanely hot
now if that is too powerful for you I
also love this one from
OWC it is Affordable and it takes one
Thunderbolt 4 port and it gives you
three more of them without any slowdowns
as well as one very fast USB type a port
which is very handy to have and then of
course it also charges your MacBook as
well so if you don't need a high-end
dock giving you one of these allows you
to plug in your display different
accessories maybe an SSD whatever else
and then with one cable bam you're
connected and you are set up now you
should also have a way to protect your
MacBook this sleeve right here is from
mof it actually has an an expansion
section where you can store accessories
you can put a card with the pocket on
the inside and it actually folds up so
you can use it as a stand with various
angles so this thing is nice and slim it
is great if you don't want to have a big
bag and if you don't want to have some
like a sleeve setup Vadim really loves
this andar which actually Clips on it's
genuine leather super high quality it
just stays on your MacBook because these
Macs are made out of aluminum and all
these edges can get dinged up pretty
easy easily you can get scratched up if
you have one of the new um black colors
so that's some that's a nice way to be
able to just protect your device so you
guys let me know what other accessories
are really worth it for your new Macbook
down in the comments section below go
ahead and click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those videos
right over there this has been Max and
I'll see you in the next
[Music]
one